allie
is in canada she has a
fitness center and a martial arts center
that they've had and invested their
careers in
for a decade plus and they finally got
reopened
after covid and now there's noise that
they may be closed
down again she's trying to figure out
how to navigate this ridiculous world
that we live in and to keep our business
alive and
our hearts breaking a little bit because
her old career has been poured into this
is that a fair summary of what you told
me so far yeah
super fair yeah um well
you know i share your frustration i've
uh
gone past the point i i have made a
commitment to god to be kind
to people who i don't agree with on
these issues and it's been very hard
because some of these people are
absolutely misbehaving
the way they're treating each other uh
the number of times i've been screeched
at
for not wearing a mask by some idiot
in a store the uh the number of times
that
i go into a business and the business
abuses me as a customer
i'm tired of it i i'm really getting
weary
the number of times that the government
of canada or the government of the
united states or the state of tennessee
or the city of nashville is denying our
freedom to operate
uh when the data is now in on this thing
it has gotten out of hand so i share
your frustration
i'm getting angry enough i'm getting
ready to start a freaking crusade
against these people but um
but the uh uh but it's gotten out of
hand
you know there are they got the amount
of totalitarianism
where the governments are just walking
in wholesale shutting down our freaking
lives
and taking them from us has gotten out
of hand
and uh that's what it feels like yeah so
i'm with you
but i don't know how to help you because
they're going to do what it looks like
and so you and i are faced with when
they do that stuff with
trying to abide by their
ridiculous decisions and they are
ridiculous based on the data that's in
or go to jail you know and of course
half our customers are cuckoo
for coconuts and so uh and the other
half
are mad at the other half and so it's
just it's it's weird
it's just a weird thing to navigate so i
i
think the problem we're facing is the
same thing we faced when there was
violence in some of the major cities
and the major cities were shut down in
america
over uh the racial issues that
in an unpredictable environment business
cannot exist
when we cannot predict order
and the only thing we can predict is
chaos
then business can't function and it
shuts down the economics of the
situation
and affects more lives than uh than the
violence
effects or then covet effects a lot more
lives
uh in a lot more negative ways so
i think that you just have you know what
we're doing is we're just having to
navigate and we're staying right on the
bleeding cutting edge
of what is allowed uh
and pushing the boundaries on what is
allowed and uh if i'm in your shoes
that's what i'm doing but the problem
is you still are not going to be able to
if they come in and just say
all gems are shut down then you're just
straight up going to jail if you open up
again
so you've got to turn around then and
uh try to find online ways to deliver
uh you know zoom workouts or uh
some kind of a digital uh curriculum
delivery of some kind uh where you still
use your passion for people's fitness
and you still use your uh your knowledge
base
uh but you're just delivering it in a
different way
and uh we'll just pray god that that
it's a temporary thing that you have to
do that that for the rest of our lives
these governments are not going well
we know they're not going to meddle at
this level because there's a bunch
there's going to be a freaking
revolution if they continue to do this
because people have had it it's not
going to go on a lot longer
i mean most people are not sheep
and uh they're just not going to do it a
lot longer so
i don't know what the what the boiling
point will be on this but
i don't predict a decade of it i can
tell you that
that we don't have workout facilities
and we don't have
gyms and we don't have martial arts for
a decade i don't think so
yeah and i think it's part two ali that
you and you guys have already done that
you've shifted you said to
work for an online company but i'm like
where are the things that you have to
get creative right i mean like even our
part of our business was just turned
upside down with live events and so now
we're having to get creative of what
that looks like of how to do events like
like it's just it it takes a different
part of your brain my kids were part of
this like little sports
class thing that's in our area and it's
so sweet and great
but they had to shut down due to covid
but then they ended up
starting this whole new department of it
let's reiterate that they had to shut
down because of government regulation
it's not because of code
i'm sorry okay well because the health
departments are over the top lost their
dadgum
minds that's why it's the dave ramsey
show you
yes correct me but but what i'm saying
is that they
and then all the k all of our schools
got shut down this spring but then they
created a whole like recess
department where the coaches would come
to neighborhoods where these
pods were of home-schooled kids now and
like have recess and
and they would they would charge for
this session so like just the creative
ways that
companies who have been shut down
through government
regulations uh because of covid19
that yeah you're just getting cr you
have to get creative i'm like it's the
only way to make money or just
or completely having to ditch the
industry and just get a job that's there
which
sucks like i don't want you to do that
ally but what the way we've gone at it
is in our business is this we've had
entire segments of the business that
just disappeared
live events is 98 gone okay
and we used to do uh 60 or 80 of these
things a year
and so i've got an entire department of
people that don't have a job i've had to
redeploy them inside the business
otherwise
so that i didn't have to fire them
because of it and
uh so we lost that so what can we do
well we can do live streams
of events and put them out there uh
they don't make any revenue to amount to
anything but we we're doing them
um and we're making a little bit of
money but more than anything we're just
helping people which we figured out a
long time ago if we can do that so
you know we're pivoting on that but
we're not pivoting on that with the idea
that live events will
never come back okay we're pivoting on
that with the idea that
for now i have to tolerate this crap
and uh my customers won't come and i got
venues that are you know the health
department and
you know 62 policemen with tactical gear
will come in and bust us because we're
all
within six feet of each other or some
kind of crap like that
and so you know it's just ridiculous and
so i've got to tolerate this for a while
and do something different for a while
and that's what you've got to do
so what you do need to ascertain is if
you really start to believe and this is
henry cloud's book necessary endings
anytime you're in a career you're in a
business you're in a situation where you
start to believe
that the that you have lost hope
that it will ever return
and this isn't being hysterical or
emotional it's how you
you know with critical thinking skills
you're looking at the landscape
i don't think this is ever going to go
back let me let me give you an example
that okay
blockbuster should have pivoted
permanently
because they should have lost hope that
people weren't going to rent
vhs tapes from them they didn't
and so they went broke because they
didn't pivot
and netflix pivoted well netflix went
from
mailing dvds but it was still it was
essentially the same business
but one didn't lose hope and one did and
so they changed
permanently who they are and
now netflix is a major operation because
of that and blockbusters is a memory
so you've got to look at that and say
permanently
what have i got to change that the
landscape is permanently changed
how much of this coveted landscape do
you believe
is permanent and you know
you know i don't believe it's permanent
because i i think it's
you know the the it's not you know
20 of population did not die
2 million people did not die you know
one thing we do know
is that you don't have to learn much
about math
to get a medical degree we have figured
that out that math people don't
medical people don't do math well that's
a permanent thing that i now know that i
didn't know before this
and so you know you've we do have a lot
of data on this
to look at it uh and to use some dad gum
common sense god that aggravates me
because
the problem is lives all over america
are like hers are being turned upside
down on this and it's
it's it's got to stop the hysteria
has got to stop this is the dave ramsey
show
[Music]